het is vandaag 22 November en dat betekent
stemmen
maar wat vinden onze redactieleden eigenlijk belangrijk
laten we dat eens aan
ze vragen eerst uh
gratis of non profit kinderopvang
omdat ik hoop dat dat
meer vrouwen naar het werkveld gaat brengen
1/2 is dat het aanpakken van het woningtekort
1 beetje betaalbare huizen gaan komen
en betaalbare woningen
en 1 eerder klimaatbeleid
ik vind 1 eerlijke huurprijs heel belangrijk
ook vind ik het standpunt
kinderopvang zonder winstoogmerk erg belangrijk
abortus niet strafbaar
dat geen enkele man in Nederland
het gevoel heeft dat hij mag en kan beslissen over
wat vrouwen met hun lichaam doen
en 1 beetje lief zijn voor alle dieren in Nederland
kinderopvang zonder winstoogmerk
en belasting op vermogen
succes met stemmen